cela nous a pas échappé sur les
émissions de sur la nutrition est ce que
c'est vraiment utile est ce que ça
intéresse les gens autant dans les
magazines féminins dès qu'on parle de
régime ça fait un carton en télé j'ai
l'impression que ça a fonctionné - alors
ça dépend vraiment du format qu'on
choisit d'accord avait dire quand on a
fait des émissions comme j'ai décidé de
maigrir on voit des gens maigrir ça
marche bien quand on fait des émissions
avec uniquement de l' expertise ça
marche bien on a testé un modèle il n'a
pas été aussi performant qu'on l'aimé en
même temps vous connaissez le principe
du carré viiip je crois et on avait fait
un carré viiip pied on avait fait un
truc avec tous les chroniqueurs de la
bande pour s'amuser etc et on avait en
face de nous un désastre pour nous c'est
à dire en même temps tf1 france 2 france
3 w9 etc
c'était impossible de dormir on va y
revenir évidemment en tous les cas on a
enquêté sur toutes ces émissions ont
regardé on en parle juste après l'été
approche à grands pas mais on ne veut
pas vous parler tout de suite donné le
bain et dont on va vous parler de
nutrition d'âge est de faire du bien là
hier soir ses 8 diffusait la grande
première de la vérité si je mange un
prime spécial présenté par valérie
benaïm
dans lequel jean michel cohen il a
appris plein de bonnes techniques pour
mieux prendre soin pour corps vous allez
manger entre 70 et 90% de grèce après
vous allez prendre le reste en protéines
et très très peu de légumes et de son
haleine donc finalement c'est le régime
qui pue de la gueule est décidément en
ce moment avoir une alimentation saine
est au centre des préoccupations de
nombreuses émissions comme dans williams
à midi très convaincant pour nous
dissuader de réchauffer votre reee vous
risquez des vomissements allez vous
faire plaisir des diarrhées et des
crampes un manque d'énergie et pour nous
éduquer quotidiennement niveau nutrition
on peut également compter sur le mac de
la santé et la quotidienne sur france 5
5l chopin en faux bond - super en
revanche la nutrition en prime ça marche
moins bien un village et la diète sur
tf1 et à table sur france 2 tout de
diffuser cet été ont été justement à la
diète niveau audience vous êtres
nombreux et ça me fait très plaisir
les programmes français plutôt soft
comparé à ce qui se fait de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique aux etats-unis dans
relooking extrême des candidats obèses
subissent un entraînement plus qu
importe si la barre est mais pour des
résultats plus que spectaculaire aussi
[Applaudissements]
devant la prolifération de toutes ses
émissions une question se pose quelle
soit sensationnel trash ou éducatives
ses émissions sur la nutrition et les
résines sont elles vraiment utile alors
il vous aimez bien les émissions alors
effectivement je suis donné ce que moi
ça me passionne parce que ma vie est un
immense régime mais visiblement il ya ça
passe pas forcément comme on dit le tube
i reçoit rebond il pour hier soir
nettement de la concurrence était
absolument incroyable il y avait des
bodin's sur m6 y avait un film sur ses
stars c'était la grosse artillerie
ça fait combien 335 devant moi donc
mais peu importe c'était plutôt bien
fait alors il faut persévérer
il faut persévérer la bouffe c'est comme
le sexe
ce sont les deux sujets pourquoi vous
pourquoi quand vous aurez la bourse vous
tout de suite vous mettez un mot un exam
aux insectes ramené deux sujets qui sont
une affaire concernant et ce sont les
deux sujets qui intéressent les français
cirque au delà de la politique était
donc il faut persévérer je pense que
c'était un cas isolé
peut-être que la promesse n'étaient pas
tenues j'en sais rien après on apprend
plein de choses moi savoir quel ouakam à
la fois à l'umd 1 calorie que laurence
alors j'ai la vie dans l'ohio alors
gilles verdez je sens que vous brillez
brouiller la patience on va avancer un
peu rires je vous donne ma parole vous
voulez recharger bien et à peu près tout
expulsés d'un coup c'est vrai
ceci dit destruction de régime à la télé
le plein d'expérience m'ont été faites
tentatives dont une sur tf1 qui était un
village à la diète
au regard des prêts dans quelques
secondes
vars va découvrir son poids est le défi
qui l'attend
faux c'est bien travaillé au niveau des
bras les films on contracte bien les
abdos bien les fesses la leçon de danse
de jean marc généreux a fait des
miracles and au bout de deux heures le
village a retenu la chorégraphie et fait
du sport sans se plaindre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là le concept était de faire en
fait de faire perdre du poids à un
village en entier il perdre 700 kg au
total est ce que finalement c'est pas
c'est un peu dur parce que c'est aussi
c'est pas une personne c'est des
personnes
j'ai une mais surtout c'est dévastateur
c'est un problème de santé publique et
on joue avec
alors hier soir je vous ai regardé
jean-michel et valérie tu as toi tu
fasses valérie mois les dominos la télé
les régimes j'adore ses déhanchements
j'ai pris ça comme du divertissement
dès qu'on veut me faire croire que c'est
sérieux un village à la diète ou dès
qu'on me faire croire qu en vous
écoutant je vais maigrir pour moi c'est
un effet répulsif
je n'y crois pas du tout même si vous
avez l'air sérieux pour moi c'est
totalement dissuasif alors je vous en
livre oui je vous offrir un cadeau avec
plaisir un très bon livre de monsieur
jean michel cohen ça fait mieux manger
pour les nuls avec pour mieux manger
parce que vous étendez visage
voilà et vous le ferez voilà alors
[Applaudissements]
évidemment le dévorer c'était le lire
c'est un jeu non mais bon il ya tout ce
qu'il faut pour pour eux oui oui c'est
ça qui ne mangeant moi ce que j'aime
bien avec vous jean michel c'est que
vous n'êtes pas un
voilà c'est pas arbeit sur le réseau
saison il faut faire attention mais on
peut même se lâcher on en a parlé et
valérie on peut faire un tel écart de
temps en temps il faut se lâcher c'est
pas comme madame ithurbide qui passe son
temps à manger rien et qui finalement ne
m'ayez pas tous allongés en parler parce
que si nous en france on peut d émission
assez assez tiède en pas se mentir sur
le régime rpt oui alors que outre
atlantique comme on dit les américains
eux vont beaucoup ses mots visuellement
vous allez voir c'est beaucoup plus ils
sont plus gros aussi spectaculaire il
adore qu'est ce qui vous fait rire vous
ils sont plus grosses et à laquelle il a
dit massa ya un problème s'appelle the
biggest loser est ce que vous connaissez
le principe
en fait c'est un concours ya deux
équipes c'est un peu comme dans koh
lanta ya les rouges et les jaunes et
doivent maigrir le plus possible est
l'équipe qui a le moins maigri et donc
sur la sellette et dans l'équipe qui a
le moins maigri y en a un qui est
forcément moins mairie que les autres
ses origines retrouve à bas c'est comme
ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord d'abord j'ai perdu 10 kilos même
un peu plus mais oui j'ai bonne mine
merci beaucoup justement sur votre type
de régime alors c'est un régime
alimentaire à base de chèques c'est est
ce que vous étiez malade vous avez la
chine au demeurant très efficace mais on
est là combien ça nous a coûté pour
perdre 10 kilos parce que les chambres
sur en fin de compte et on a perdu cinq
kilos grâce à vous moi jamais je sais et
dont c'est la troisième envoyée sorti
une des solutions à tous que vous payer
60 euros vous envoyer des vidéos avec un
sportif avec quelques conseils nutrition
et dégoûté je suivais ça pendant 13
semaines
as a marché à wells et tétouan on va pas
faire çà cette eau sur mon cas bigger
than others donc le prince et vous
l'avez compris cette émission j'ai rêvé
de l'adapter en france mais
malheureusement je crois que c'est
impossible pour des questions de
législation notamment de publicité pour
les chirurgiens à la télévision c'est
interdit en france alors que en amérique
on peut faire absolument tout ce qu'on
veut regarder c'est très impressionnant
rodez
[Musique]
est-ce que sans aller aussi loin on peut
pas trouver un format qui soit
concernant où les gens se retrouvent ou
7 'fuiter' c'est à dire on peut les
suivre par exemple sur quelques mois et
on les voit maigrir parce que le
problème du donne une ride le marché on
travaille sur ce projet là bas elle
dispose moi j'aimerais aller à l'époque
il y avait eu avec jean luc delarue de
joie après jour où il suffirait donc
dans le cadre d'un documentaire vous
pouvez suivre des gens qui sont en train
de faire un régime
on a fait sur mes sauts et qui la mérite
mais dans le cas des en parle d'un
documentaire en cas de démission on
appelle de flux dont elle n'a pas droit
au passé alors
christine kelly qu'est notre sage de me
dire pourquoi on n'a pas le droit en
france
oui mais en fait comme pour les avocats
les médecins les avocats les revélois la
l'égérie de la publicité
donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu délicat
on ne peut pas prôner à mettre en avant
lui le même c'est nul ce dépendamment
question conquête mois producteur est ce
que je peux faire une émission où je
vais filmer une période qui se fait
anesthésiés raboter levante sérieuse
qu'on appelle l'aide de place si ça vous
coupe le droit de le faire ou pas bien
sûr j'ai droit de le faire j'ai envie de
filmer j aime bien s'amuser
mais après il faut mettre interdiction
moins d'ici là le moment de la diffusion
on peut pas diffuser à 9 h chez moi
alors je vais plus loin que ça des
rondeurs comme mon fils on peut filmer
en gros plan déjà dieu je vais plus loin
devant j'ai fait cette émission je ne
vends une chaîne mais mon nom mon
patient on les saisies mari serait mais
pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
on vous entend pas tout seul il y avait
un format extraordinaire qui s'appelait
relooking extrême à bellion est génial
et celle adaptée en france c'était
impossible pour des raisons légales vous
n'avez pas le droit de de faire des
opérations en direct de les diffuser en
face et on n'a pas le droit